there's plenty of action in the first
batch of episodes of the long-awaited
third season of The Witcher but its
political Intrigue that really ramps up
the Drama by the end here's how all the
twists and turns play out warning
spoilers for season 3 volume 1 of The
Witcher ahead Jennifer geralt and Siri
begin the season hiding from most of the
world as Siri trains in Magic and Yen
Works to rebuild trust with geralt when
riences revealed to have a vial of
Siri's blood which means that he can
always find her Yen and Siri leave for
aratuza and they briefly part ways with
geralt who goes on to visit a castle
inhabited by a multi-limbed Abomination
made from the bodies of young women with
magical Affinity at aratusa Jennifer
tries to adapt back into the hedonistic
selfish ways of her fellow Brotherhood
members to clear a safe path for Siri
after seeing Siri's disappointment in
her behavior though she instead
convinces the Brotherhood to host a
conclave for all of the northern Mages
in hopes that they'll combine forces and
help bring a peaceful resolution to the
milfguardian conflict meanwhile Tris has
been noting The Disappearance of many of
the aratuza apprentices vilgaforth a
mage who has been to say as romantic
partner since at least the Battle of
sodden Hill leads the Brotherhood
Council Jennifer previously maintained a
healthy skepticism of bilgaforts but in
season 3 she decides to prioritize and
value the people she loves including to
Saya as a result yennefer accepts
bilgaforts and specifically notes the
beautiful Redstone bracelet he gave to
seya earlier
for what it's worth
I'm happy to see the person she's become
around you
some characters don't appear in the
mid-season finale the fifth episode of
the volume because it all takes place at
the r2's a conclave ball most
importantly the last we see of Syria and
yaskir is in the fourth episode they
spend the night of the conclave in a
spell protected Cottage on thanet island
Siri spends most of the episode with
geralt fighting a sea beast on their way
to r2's Island she discusses her hopes
for the future of the continent as well
as her own life Siri is getting tired of
running and she's proven herself a
formidable fighter thanks to the
training she has received from geralt
and the other Winters yaskir for his
part is Keen to further explore his
crush and rodania's Crown Prince after
radovid finds him at the cabin kahir who
has killed his friend Gallatin to prove
his loyalty to Amir finds his way to the
elves led by Francesca on amir's orders
kahir and Francesca will be banning
together to search for Siri in volume 2.
the mid-season finale opens after the
end of the conclave ball geralt and
yennefer are already in their private
chamber at first it seems like we may
not get to see what happened at the ball
at all as they start to undress and
recount the night together but soon
enough there's a flashback to where we
left Carrollton yet at the end of the
previous episode viewers are shown
Snippets of various conversations around
the ball geralt promises Yen he'll be on
his best behavior stop eating like an
underfed gluten after dodging Sabrina's
advances The Witcher finds time to speak
to Philippa and then dijkstra both of
whom were at the conclave to represent
the interests of rodania Jennifer checks
in with desea and vilgaforts before
taking a one-on-one stroll with Philippa
their conversation is not audible but
geralt soon sees Yen's Old Flame istrid
Interruption for a private seemingly
serious conversation with her thanks to
a comment from bilgaforts regarding the
Persistence of First Love geralt appears
to be jealous of Yen and istrid and
later picks a fight with istrid
following the melange a courtly dance in
which partners are repeatedly Switched
Off Yin appears upset but soon after the
resolution of the light to see a
curiously raises a toasty Jennifer and
geralt for facilitating a night of peace
and Hope back in their private chamber
geralt and yennefer are analyzing the
events of the night there's another
flashback to the start of the ball and
viewers realize that Yen and geralt were
executing a plan to apprehend stregabore
whom they believed to be the secret
malevolent force behind many of the
recent Horrors that they've experienced
this time around we catch many more of
geralt and yennefer's conversations with
the other attendees which provides a lot
of clarity as to the real reason for the
tension in both geralt and Yan's
demeanors Philippa suddenly and
unsuccessfully interrogates Carol for
information before geralt receives a
warning from dijkstra that he will need
to choose a side in the conflict very
soon if he hopes to keep Siri safe
istrith tells yennefer that he and tris
have discovered that streakabor is
responsible for the theft of the book of
monoliths geralt's fight with istrid is
merely a distraction
[Music]
you've been trying to win Yen back all
evening it gives Ian a chance to find a
list of the park Elven Mages in
stregabore safe stregabore finds her but
is soon joined by geralt Tris istrid to
Saya villegafort and Artorias istrid
reveals that the book of monoliths which
is in stragivore's possession provides
the Brotherhood with enough proof to
have him arrested stregabore maintains
his innocence as he is dragged away and
once again tasaya tells Yen and geralt
that they saved the night
geralt and yennefer are happily
celebrating their Victory with a bath
when Jennifer points out that Philippa
was acting strangely at the ball she was
expecting Philippa and dijkstra to come
into the conclave with their own agenda
and schemes what Yen was not expecting
was to receive a warning from Philippa
regarding the Brotherhood and their
conclave efforts Philippa heavily
implies that the conclave is doomed to
fail because there are malevolent forces
at work she points out Lydia the Mage
who can only communicate via telepathy
because of a ruinous injury to her face
which he hides with illusion magic Lydia
is a slave to her lover incapable of
parting with a poison that is slowly
killing her geralt realizes that Lydia
has been working with riyans and
Jennifer recalls that the stones in
Lydia's earrings are the same as those
in to saya's bracelet they slowly begin
to realize that they've been played
after geralt recounts his own
conversation with vilgaforts who spoke
of his violent past the power of love
and the fact that geralt needed to
choose a side it's incredible how much
fun you travel to the outrage is
everyone they hear screams only seconds
after realizing that bilgaforth was
behind rian's actions all law Jennifer
runs to find to Saya and geralt is
stopped by Dykstra in the hallway with a
knife to the throat
for viewers who aren't familiar with the
book series upon which the show is based
the reveal of vilgaforts as the True
Villain is really well executed it's a
definite should have seen it coming
moment the character had more screen
time and faced more suspicion from
yennefer in the first two seasons but in
the first half of season 3 he mainly
serves as a supportive partner to tasaya
and a thoughtful member of the
Brotherhood Council the trick is that
the writers have been engendering hatred
for stregabore since the very first
episode in which he admitted to killing
any young women born during and
immediately following the black Sun He
was largely responsible for renfrey's
death and totally responsible for her
assault and the ruin of her life ever
since then he's been a bigoted creepy
thorn in the sight of any character with
whom he's come into contact the audience
wanted stregabore to be responsible for
everything that's been going wrong so
that he could finally get his
comeuppance so it was easier to believe
that he was a relatively straightforward
answer to one of the show's most elusive
Mysteries
Philippa and taseya were once close
friends and until episode 5 we didn't
know why they had a falling out Philippa
tells yennefer that she warned to say
about unconditional loyalty and though
she didn't mention vilgafort's by name
it's clear by the end of the episode
that his influence over to Saya forced a
wedge between them she and Yen are not
exactly allies but Philippa believes
that yennefer is capable of seeing past
bilga for its deceptions Tris sees
geralt for the first time since she fled
care Morin Tris has still not forgiven
herself for failing to protect Syrian
and she won't be able to hide from her
fears at aratusa for much longer but
it's nice to see Tris and isstrid
working together to do what they think
is right both of them have always stood
out from their peers as slightly more
self-aware and morally accountable it's
bittersweet though to see to say his
short-lived happiness she finally has
Jennifer back in vilgaforts is by her
side and the Brotherhood is making
progress toward a better future for
Mages in the continent but her world is
about to be blown apart with the
Revelation that vilgaforth is plotting
against them and there's no guarantee
that she'll live through the next
episode to mourn her relationship
the ending of volume 1 has huge
implications for the story Jennifer
believes she's made ratusa safe for Siri
but is caught off guard when bilgaforce
reveals that he's been working against
her all along and that's just the
beginning it seems like everyone is
after Siri Amir emperor of nilfiger
wants his daughter and heir to the
throne back Francesca believes Siri is
the Fulfillment of an ancient prophecy
dixtra is obsessed with using her powers
to gain a tactical advantage over his
foes and in episode 3 the wild Hunt
begins their Chase of the Lost lion cub
of sintra
[Music]
death itself
geralt Jennifer are the only people
truly looking out for series welfare but
Siri is starting to make it difficult
she's growing in power and confidence
and is realizing that she may be the
only person who can resolve the conflict
their world is facing
the events of The Witcher season 3
volume 1 run roughly parallel to the
first half of the fifth novel in The
Witcher book series time of contempt
while the writers of the show have made
changes to characters like Francesca
giving them larger more emotionally
complex roles their first installment of
season 3 stays quite loyal to the plot
of the book series however showrunner
Lauren hisrick has said that the show
will not always be faithful to the books
Henry Cavill who recently announced that
he will be leaving the show and stepping
away from the part of geralt after
season 3 has fully concluded has never
publicly said why he decided to leave
the show other than to pursue other
projects but many fans and Industry
insiders have speculated that he was
disappointed with the direction of the
story Cabell has long claimed to be a
big fan of the books and it seems that
not everyone working on the show has the
same passion for the source material
Lauren histrick told Entertainment
Weekly That season 3 will provide the
most heroic send-off they could manage
for cavill's exit from the show it's
also been announced that Liam Hemsworth
will take over his geralt starting with
season four
what does the end of season 3 volume 1
of The Witcher mean for season 3 volume
2. the second part of the season will
release on Netflix on July 27th a little
under a month after volume 1. based on a
comment from showrunner Laura hisrick it
sounds like this season of The Witcher
will continue to stick pretty Faithfully
to the plot of the fifth Witcher novel
time of contempt Volume 2 will most
likely pick up right where volume 1 left
off with dijkstra holding a knife to
geralt's neck as Jennifer seeks to make
sure to Saya is still alive season 3
volume 2 promises to be action-packed
and filled with political machinations
and many of the power players in The
Witcher Universe are starting to play
their hands more so than ever before
basically everyone of note is trying to
find Siri either because of her magical
abilities or her royal and Elven
Heritage audiences will most likely now
get to see vilgafort stepping out of the
Shadows to embrace his villainy a little
more this is especially true now that
geralt and Jennifer have discovered that
he is the one who has been behind so
many of the strange and terrible
happenings of late
foreign